jody i don't know where you are but you
look like you were living your best life
queen
i am living my best life
it's the weather it's the glow i'm like
let me
in i want to go i'm in jamaica
[Laughter]
oh that is so nice are you getting to
like enjoy jamaica or are you working
i mean i'm working right now but you're
enjoying it
but i'm enjoying myself you know this is
the only this is the work portion
of the trip so and at least i'm walking
by you know
thankfully i love what i do yeah so
it's okay i don't mind working for these
few days oh my god
you are literally the most wanted
actress in hollywood
like do you wake up and realize this is
to be true
i hope so we'll see you know
well you are such a joy to watch in this
film as you are in everything that you
do
um what was it like working with michael
b jordan in this
yeah you know michael is a really sweet
guy
and he's very funny and you know i love
that he
i love how important it is to him to
have an inclusive set
um you know i think what he's doing with
his company is really wonderful and
amazing
for people of color in the business and
in the industry i've sort of been
demanding that there's representation
for us not just in front of the camera
but behind it
yes you know i think that is really
really really very important
yeah um and you know it was
it was a wild ride i mean i i i did this
film while i was pregnant
so obviously that just makes
everything a little bit different yeah
yeah you know um it's the body is
moving and working differently and and
to sort of push my body to
do what everybody else was doing while
it was doing something
so delicate and important and vital
was really really intense you know but
i came out of that experience i think
stronger and
i definitely learned a lot i definitely
learned a lot about
just even just you know having to make
sure i think as women oftentimes we sort
of
because we're so used to being given a
short end of the stick
we're so used to being you know kind of
treated as though we're less than
even though it's like wow we're really
drinking not really
they could never do what we do um but
it it for that reason i think there's
always a reluctance
to you know when we're we're told to
apologize for our presence and our
existence not speak up for ourselves i
think
this was definitely a moment for me in
my career where i learned
like being in the space
asking for what i need because i
realized that
you know i am so blessed and privileged
to be able to do something that i really
love
and i'm also really powerful doing
something that biologically is my birth
right
and that uh 85 percent of the people
that i was around
actually obviously 90 because it you
know still sets a very male heavy
so it was definitely you know it was a
it was a it was a
it was a learning and growing experience
visual
yeah definitely
yeah you know we've been asking a lot of
stars you know what has been their most
joyful experience in lockdown because
it's a lot of negative but
you know what is the one positive that
you know everyone
is getting from lockdown and i'm
assuming because it brought a huge smile
to your face
you know having a baby that must be
yours yeah 100
and you know what's really been
beautiful about it too is that it
is that she has been the most joyful
part of
the experience of many people in my
circle and that's the joy that
that you get from new life you know like
for my mother
yeah well this could have been a time
that was just like such a dark cloud for
everyone because we had this baby
for so many of us in my family and that
are touched by her
it has been this moment of joy you know
because we get to
rally around and cultivate this really
precious
little life and that has been such a
blessing
to us all and just a reminder of the
fact that you know there are cycles in
life
of life and death of decay abroad but
also of beauty and growth
and we are so lucky to get to witness
that right in our home
i love that we're also so lucky to
witness you
as anne boleyn we saw the teaser
we saw the teaser so you see my reaction
but what has the reaction been like
you know what listen you know i i've
been kind of
keeping away from looking into too much
what the reaction is like because you
know
as there's there's been there's been a
wildly positive
response but then there's also you know
as is the case when a black person takes
a role in anything that people
you know because even beyond even if i
were to be doing
you know something that was in a sci-fi
fantasy world black woman i still get so
much
attack from people being like ah and you
know for some people it's certainly
polarizing this idea of playing
a a strong competitor
you know i took this role because it was
more about
you know telling a story that was human
story about some women's story but
you know every woman no matter what your
race
or your socioeconomic background you
know
we're talking about common things that
we all experience and in terms of
our ambition for ourselves and our
children
you know the things we come up against
yeah
what people say are our limitations and
fighting through that
i feel like as a black woman those are
things i can really understand and i
just wanted to give my take on this
story
yeah you know are you excited
your co-star queen slim daniel best
supporting actor academy awards
i mean i won better win he better win
i am so excited for him i feel the same
way so excited for him
you're so talented did you watch him uh
hold saturday night live
yes i watch it it was so good he's so
good he's so talented
i mean just judas and the black messiah
in general i just okay
what three times three i've watched it
three times
oh you have me beat you have me be i
only watch it twice
yeah so good three times
oh my gosh and purple yeah
no he's totally incredible in it and
we're all sad to hear yesterday
that you couldn't do the new series the
witcher blood origin because you busy
apparently you were busy girl you know i
think it's not the first time in my life
that i'm probably gonna have to
make a hard choice because the way that
things or choices kind of get made for
me because of the way that
the world is moving in my life is moving
but i was just so excited
that i was even in that conversation
with them and and i'm really excited to
find something else for us sometime in
the future and you know we'll see
i mean it would have been a really cool
universe to step into but
you know the things that i meant for me
are mine i like to say that's my mantra
and so you know while i won't be able to
do that
you know i'm really excited for for what
is coming next so
i love that thank you it was so nice to
talk to you
please enjoy my [ __ ] youtube thank
you talk to you too
thank you and you are absolutely
stunning
thank you you're stunning